à l'origine l'idée de créer une
commission ad-hoc entre élus
martiniquais pour définir une stratégie
pour sortir du confinement est une bonne
idée
au fil des réunions cette idée s'est
révélé être un simulacre de consultation
et la commission a été dissous
aujourd'hui par son président elle se
termine en eau de boudin
en effet nous n'avons ni calendrier ni
procédure claire ont procédé à la
commande des masques du gel
hydroalcoolique et d autres équipements
il n'y a pas non plus une procédure
particulière qui a été mise en oeuvre
pour permettre aux entreprises
martiniquaises qui fabrique gel masque
équipements de vendre ses produits à la
collectivité qui distribueraient s'est
produit à la population en matière de
transport un calendrier a été annoncé
mais ce que l'on peut noter c'est que la
ctm ne participera pas un autogoal
sanitaires afin d'aider les opérateurs
pourquoi cette partie sanitaires
importantes
les chauffeurs de taxi n'ont pas du tout
été évoquée ce que l'on peut dire c'est
que cette commission traduit bien la
situation de la majorité qui est divisée
est ce qu'on peut dire c'est que comme
pour l'eau elle est en cale sèche